Alright so this first of, Bjorn's questions, I'll just read it word
for word because this is coming straight from the instructor of the
course. so at first sight, current physics seems to be concerned with
sophisticated mathematics. Like Riemannian manifolds, self-adjoint
operators, path integrals over anti-commuting spaces
[LAUGH].
But, wouldn't it be fair to say that most of this higher mathematics in the end
boils down to differential equations. Even if we're
dealing with elementary particles or with the entire universe.
>> It almost always has to do with differential equations. it, let
me take back one phrase, Almost. It always has to do with
differential equations, yes. It may be
that other things, other mathematical things
are more important than the differential equations in this particular area or
that particular area. But it always has to do with differential equations, yes.
>> Why is that? Why is it that differential equations become the
>> Because what we're interested in is how things vary. You know where physics
is about It's prediction. Basically, to predict
the future from the present or the future
from the past and that means understanding
how things change. And you not only want
to understand how they change with time,
but you want to understand how they change
with space. You, like for example, you want to
predict the weather. Alright we theoretical physicists usually
don't predict the weather. But they do predict similar kinds
of things. How do you predict the weather? Well the first
thing you have to know is called an initial condition. You
have to know what the weather is exactly every wheres on
the earth. What does that mean? That means you need to
know the pressure, you need to know the temperature. Whatever it
is, you need to know the wind velocity, and these are
all a bunch of things which vary from place to place.
So, the first thing you have to input is the conditions at an instant of
time. Now, you want to know how they change. How do they change? They change by
little incremental changes from instant to instant. And
the incremental changes at one position depend on
what's going on in the region nearby that
one position. Whenever you have a situation where
the change in something depends on what's
going on nearby, that's a partial differential
equation. That's a partial. So whenever you're
in the business of predicting how the
world changes. Or how some part of the world changes both with respect to
position and with respect to time, you're
in the business of partial differential equations.